should win allowance if you're a public
official should one allow one's faith to
influence one's decisions now in the
philosophical literature surrounding the
Rawls discussion the people who are
defenders of Rawls well usually will
often operate with an extremely
stereotypical view of a religious reason
and it always goes like this God told me
so so it must be so hmmm rarely is that
how it goes suppose suppose your
religion leads you to believe that
involuntary poverty is not just a call
for charity but a matter of Rights that
the poor have the Valen involuntarily
poor have a right to fair access to
decent means of sustenance something
like that suppose that's suppose your
religious tradition has led you to
believe it it's not so simple that God
told you one night you know and so forth
that complicated thing how would how
would you not let it can shape your
decisions if you were the present in
dealing with the US health care mess and
you had that conviction how would you
how would you not let it shape your
thinking about poor people without
health care and now and how could it be
wrong to let her do that